here is our black lesbian press
secretary Karin Jean-Pierre referring uh
well she's talking about
what's going on with the FBI and the
hunter Biden story and oh she's just go
the latest Twitter files show that the
intelligence Community was actively
involved in discrediting the hunter
Biden laptop story does it bother the
president and those at the White House
that a government agency like the FBI
was involved in suppressing a legitimate
news story again I'm just going to refer
you to the FBI I'm not going to comment
from here about that it's so wild she's
so as I said yesterday there's no one in
the history of the world that could be
worse at their job than she is at her
job she's so transparently dishonest the
question was how does Biden feel about
it how does the administration feel now
knowing that the FBI was in cahoots with
big Tech to take out the hunter Biden
story The the question was not did you
guys have anything to do with it why
could she not say very clearly
um we don't really like the idea of our
agencies working with private companies
to silence Americans and quash stories
that are of importance to the average
American right why don't why couldn't
she say that well the obvious answer to
that is she's thrilled about it right
this is what the swamp is the Democrats
more than the Republicans but the
Republicans too the Democrats and big
Tech and these agencies they work to
silence information you don't know
exactly what the truth is as I always
say the truth is now A Time release pill
so usually a year or two later you
actually get to the truth and a whole
bunch of people who are wrong about
everything pretend that they were there
the entire time and then it causes the
people who are right about most of the
stuff to really start getting annoyed at
everybody else because it's like come on
guys like get on the get on the ship
here already like get on board come on
come on but they keep lying they keep
censoring